See that city?
It was my city before the Rat King took it from me.
His kingdom was overthrown,...
...a curse was cast upon him,...
No!
...and he was banished from his world forever.
Merry Christmas, you two.
Meet, NC.
Until one magical night,...
...he discovered someone who could change everything.
Hello, Mary.
You can talk.
I've been waiting for someone like you.
Only you have the power to break the curse.
I'm going back to fight the Rat King and reclaim my kingdom.
Will you join me?
Yes.
Is this real?
Reality is merely an illusion.
You did it.
I knew you'd believe.
The spell on the prince is broken.
This holiday season...
It's so beautiful.
...experience one of the most beloved stories of our time...
Sorry.
...like you've never dreamt it before...
Wow! Can you do that again, please?
...in 3D.
I've got a plan!
Elle Fanning, Nathan Lane, and John Turturro.
Say hello and goodbye to your prince!
We have to stop him.
Watch out!
The Nutcracker in 3d.